comme le dit damien le plus jeune pilote
du championnat de france de rallycross
ça c'est sa voiture de tous les jours à
tout juste 17 ans n'ayant pas encore son
permis de conduire il roule dans cette
petite voiture électrique qui ne dépasse
pas les 45 km heure et quand je passe du
dimanche soir la supercar à la twizy
c'est complètement différent différents
et pour cause 560 sa fédération
chez les meuniers c'est toute la famille
qui est passionné par les voitures et
qui a été pilote le virus vient du grand
père qui a commencé dans les années 70
sont deux chevaux cross mais aujourd'hui
c'est tout le clan meunier qui se
retrouvent pour soutenir damien lepers
anthony s'occupe lui aussi de
l'organisation comme moi voilà en 2016
championne féminine et du coup quelques
minutes avant le départ
anthony laisse l'organisation de côté
l'important est d'aller soutenir son
fils damien qui va courir sa première
manche
[Musique]
alors que damien est en tête il fait une
petite erreur est mort sur le bas côté
une suspension casse pour cette manche
c'est la déception
l'enfant du pays par tout de même sous
les applaudissements donc voilà c'est
vraiment on était vraiment dans un bon
tempo
je me sentais vraiment bien dans la
voiture c'est oui c'est un petit peu
dommage mais bon on va se rattraper et à
la suite derrière il ya la suite tout le
monde s'affaire autour de la voiture il
faut la réparer au plus vite pour courir
les autres manches demain dimanche
damien espère bien faire partie des huit
pilotes qui s'affronteront pour la
finale dont le départ est prévu à 15h30